10:161 wenn ich das Internet zerstören
wollen würde wie würde man das anstellen
also ich frage von Freund nee also jetzt
mal ehrlich kann man ja man kann also
eure oberflächlich nicht es sei denn sie
kann Bagger fahren naja wir haben uns
angeschaut wie man das Internet kaputt
machen könnte und bringen euch das
wahrscheinlich unterhaltsamste
weltuntergangsvideo dass wir je gemacht
haben
es begann alles damit dass wir Internet
Zerstörung gegoogelt haben und das
sofort bereut haben weil das eine ganze
Woche ist
aber wenn man ein bisschen weiter sucht
kann man tatsächlich herausfinden wie
man das Internet selber theoretisch
abschalten könnte long story Shorts gibt
da verschiedene Möglichkeiten von sehr
kompliziert bis zu sehr einfach
also ihr geht in den Baumarkt kauft euch
eine
und buddelt eines der weltumspannenden
Unterseekabel dort aus wo sie an Land
treffen hier zum Beispiel oder hier denn
das Internet funktioniert nicht mal halb
so kabellos wie unser WLAN uns das
glauben machen will die großen
Datenströme dieser Welt zwischen den
Ländern und Kontinenten fließen alle
durch Unterseekabel Großbritannien hat
einige damit du dir viel Graben für
Westafrika hingegen reicht ein einzelner
Schnitt an der richtigen Stelle dann
sind Länder an der Küste erstmal vom
globalen Internet getrennt das ganze
Internet habt ihr damit natürlich noch
nicht zerstört aber es ist ein Anfang
für die die etwas mehr wollen empfehlen
wir die Fortgeschrittenen Variante die
satelliteninfrastruktur des Internets
also nicht die Satelliten da oben das
ist eine etwas vertracktere Geschichte
wie man damit mischt dazu haben wir vor
ein paar Wochen ein leider ziemlich
gruseliges Video gemacht dass ihr euch
hier ansehen könnt doch zu jedem
anständigen satellitennetz gehören auch
Bodenstationen die sind besser geschützt
als die Kabel aber ihr könnt von außen
den Funkverkehr mit sogenannten jammern
stören sofern ihr das aber nicht
weltweit mit sich Komplizen genau
gleichzeitig macht ist das allenfalls
ein kleiner hick-up im weltweiten
Datenfluss
wer das Internet temporär etwas
weitläufiger lahm liegen möchte der
sollte sich für die Profi-Variante
entscheiden einen Cyberangriff es gibt
verschiedene Ideen aber bei fast allen
schlägt man das Internet mit seinen
eigenen Waffen denn es besteht aus der
Vernetzung von unzähligen Servern auf
denen die Daten liegen um dieses
Netzwerk geht es übrigens auch hier
nicht um die Löschung von Daten die man
im Internet findet das ist tatsächlich
stand jetzt nicht möglich im Falle von
meinem alten schülerverzer Profil nicht
gut aber generell natürlich gut aber
auch die Netze des Internets sind
ziemlich robust gebaut das Zauberwort
heißt Pakete jede Datenmenge die durch
das Internet geschickt wird wird in
viele kleine Pakete aufgeteilt um die
schnellste Route zu finden pingen die
Server das heißt mit Hilfe einer Art
Testsignal wird die kürzeste Route
errechnet auf diese werden dann die
Pakete geschickt der Vorteil ist jetzt
wenn es auf einer Route eine Überlastung
gibt oder einen Server gerade nicht
erreichbar ist können Pakete einfach
über eine andere Route umgeleitet werden
an sich also eine super Sache die unter
anderem so designt wurde damit man das
Internet eben nicht einfach so lahmlegen
kann wie Idioten wollen das jetzt
natürlich trotzdem machen zum Glück
sagen manche forschende dass man gerade
diese Eigenschaft auch gegen das
Netzwerk selber wenden könnte dafür
braucht man erstmal ein botnetzwerk das
ist sowas wie eine Armee von Fremden
Geräten die der Hacker für seine eigenen
Zwecke nutzen kann es kann eure Heizung
mit digitalen Thermostat sein eure
smarte Zahnbürste euer Staubsauger
vielleicht sogar euer smarter Blumentopf
was gibt's heutzutage eigentlich nicht
alles
meistens bekommt man das als Besitzer
dieser Geräte übrigens überhaupt nicht
mit wenn Sie in einer solchen bot Armee
sind das solltet ihr mal überprüfen wir
haben euch hier unter dieser Quelle eine
Website verlinkt die beschreibt wie das
geht mit Hilfe dieses Netzwerkes
identifiziert man jetzt einzelne
besonders wichtige Server Verbindungen
des Internets und trennt Sie mehr dazu
findet übrigens dann in dieser Quelle
hier die Server an beiden Enden der
Verbindung sagen nun allen anderen
Servern Bescheid dass sie gerade mal
kurz Kaffee holen sind kurz darauf gehen
sie wieder ans Netz und informieren
darüber alle anderen Server das
botnetzwerk trennt die ausgewählte
Verbindung wieder die verbinden sich sie
trennen sich sie verbinden sich ich
glaube ich verstehe das Prinzip der Clou
bei diesem Gedankenspiel ist die status
updates häufen sich der Art dass das
System irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr
in der Lage ist die eigentlichen
Informationen durch das Internet zu
transportieren es ist also effektiv
lernen gelegt
eine andere Angriffsmethode mit so einem
botnetzwerk hat es tatsächlich schon mal
gegeben am 21 oktober 2002 da haben
Hacker die 13 DNS Root Server des
Internets angegriffen die sind quasi das
Adressbuch des Internets denn Adressen
sind schwer zu merken keplalan 1 2202 AZ
Nordwijk Niederlande z.B oder war das
2202 bei IP-Adressen ist es sogar noch
schwieriger daher haben Websites Namen
www.dr.at eine ganz besonders tolle oder
www.wikipedia.org habt ihr davon schon
mal gehört diese DNS Root Server
übersetzen die Adresse die wir eingeben
in die entsprechende IP sprich ohne
dieses Server kommt im Internet fast
nichts dort an wo es hin soll im Oktober
2002 bombardierten Hacker sie 75 Minuten
lang mit derart vielen Anfragen dass 9
von 13 überlastet waren sie konnten
keine tatsächlichen Anfragen mehr
beantworten ziemlich effektiv
aber zugegeben dauerhaft lahmgelegt hat
dass das Internet auch noch nicht
dafür braucht ihr Methode Nummer vier
Internet zerstören für Diktatoren und
alle anderen Staaten damit könnt ihr das
Internet in einem ganzen Land abschalten
die dafür müsstet ihr allerdings wie der
Name schon sagt eine Exekutive
befehligen und wahrscheinlich auch kein
besonders netter Typ sein dann könnt ihr
die nämlich einfach den Internet Service
Providern eures Landes Befehlen euer
Land vom globalen Internet zu trennen
und dann ist das Internet in eurem Land
wirklich für so lange wie ihr wollt tot
so in Teilen passiert im Iran unter
anderem
oder hat mein Onkel gesagt der wen von
einer Behörde kennt der wen vom Militär
kennt der eine Putzfrau kennt naja ist
ja auch egal wenn man wirklich richtig
effektiv und auf einen Schlag das
gesamte Internet ausschalten wollen
würde dann greift man am besten das
Stromnetz an danke fürs zuhören und der
heutige teddog zum Thema wie zerstöre
ich das Internet wurde euch präsentiert
von ERA ab aber hey moment mal waren die
nicht wegen mangelnder Nachhaltigkeit in
der Kritik das haben wir uns für euch am
Ende unseres Videos zu neuen Wasser mal
genauer angesehen mit trinke ich im
Prinzip normales Leitungswasser frei von
Zusatzstoffen Zucker oder Kalorien aber
durch die aromaports oben auf der
Flasche schmeckt es nicht so das Wasser
schmeckt jetzt zwar nicht gerade wie
Cola oder wie Orangensaft aber es ist
auch nicht mehr nur langweiliges Wasser
gleichzeitig gibt es weniger Müll durch
einwegplastikflaschen und es hat mir
persönlich dabei geholfen mehr zu
trinken okay aber was ist jetzt mit der
Nachhaltigkeit von Arab die Post
bestehen zwar aus Plastik sind aber
immerhin aus recycelbare Material
hergestellt werden die Kapseln
inzwischen in Holland die
Edelstahlflasche die kommt aus China
noch soll aber auch bald in der EU
hergestellt werden und auch die
Herstellung der tritanflasche wurde
schon nach Österreich geholt perfekt ist
die CO2-Bilanz noch nicht aber das
Unternehmen bewegt sich in die richtige
Richtung gut sagen jetzt einige man
könnte auch einfach Leitungswasser im
Glas trinken da eine Zitrone
reinquetschen und 100% Plastik und CO2
einsparen und das stimmt aber seid mal
ehrlich wer macht das wirklich und wer
kauft sich dann doch eher eine Cola oder
Wasser mit Geschmack in der
Plastikflasche das ist die Zielgruppe
die erot gerne erreichen und
nachhaltiger machen möchte ihr merkt
selbst dass ihr manchmal vergesst
ausreichend viel zu trinken gerade jetzt
im Sommer dann klick auf den Link in der
Beschreibung holt euch mit dem Code dr
Watson 10% Rabatt und probiert es selbst
mal aus